It's time for Drew's News,
your daily shot of good news wheat grass
straight down the gullet.
(Ross gulps)
(hand taps)
(Ross chuckles)
With me at the desk is my favorite co-pilot,
Rossy Ross Matthews.
Hi everybody, hi.
(audience cheers)
Hi guys.
And today, we're joined by a fantastic guest.
He is the bestselling author of "Think Like A Monk."
And now he's the chief purpose officer at Calm,
the app that helps us all be a little more mindful.
What a success that's become.
Love that app.
Thank goodness.
Watch this.
The Daily Jay is seven mindful minutes.
We're going to talk about purpose, values, meaning,
habits and goals, relationships, communication.
We're going to learn how to master our minds.
I--
(audience applauding)
Please welcome the one, the only, Jay Shetty.
Hi.
Aw, I'm so happy.
(audience applauding)
I'm so glad to have you.
It's so great to be here.
(audience applauding)
I love listening to you.
You've got such a soothing voice.
I don't know about a soothing voice, I wish I had one
but you have that thing that makes us take a moment
and thinking...
If people are watching this right now and they think,
"Okay, I wanna start my personal journey of wellness."
What's something they can do today.
Okay, so I'm going to give you something for your body,
something for your mind and something for your heart.
Okay?
So for your body,
I want everyone to just get their 10,000 steps in per day.
It's simple.
It is simpler than you think.
Take a walk, move around.
It's so powerful and so simple.
For your mind, meditation may sound scary,
it may sound intimidating, it's a bit challenging,
but if you can just take seven minutes every single day
to meditate, to just schedule time with yourself,
no distractions, just to be present with yourself.
And then for your heart, share gratitude with someone.
If you can thank someone
for something that they've done for you today,
someone that maybe you even forgotten about,
someone probably from your past
who did something really small,
but led to this big impact in your life.
If you remember them,
I promise you you're going to walk away feeling phenomenal.
So that would be the three things.
We can do that.
(gentle music)